[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
wait up gaps slow down
look there's the Eiffel Tower J's this
bag is heavy I'm just gonna set up this
shots and then you must jump on my back
okay you ready
[Music]
I think a waves coming
oh yes away oh [ __ ] a barrel
[Music]
you're it's really windy and tough to
walk into a bar please stop complaining
there's the pyramids are you happy now
perhaps I know the pyramids don't
interest to match but please let's just
get a drone shots please
okay I'm sorry yeah take this drone
controller get rid of the bag okay
sit this guy up pass the remote okay
cool now wave goodbye to the drain okay
oh yeah hell yeah
check those news but it's been a year
[Applause]
yes
like that whoops well some assault
landed on you
[Music]
[Applause]
gabs can I take a photo of you quick
sure this was the best trip ever
thank you so much for watching that
rapid race around the world honeymoon
video when obviously you know I hope he
realized that we weren't actually in
Paris or flying my drones over the
pyramids that was all yeah at my house
in our lounge and even though it wasn't
a real honeymoon and gaps are now
supposed to be on our actual real
honeymoon right now
we definitely have so much fun just
creating these creative quirky short
little videos so it's been really
awesome and an amazing honeymoon to be
able to grow creatively together and
start to work off one another's ideas
through utilizing what we have which is
really restricting because of the
lockdown so all in all we're really
happy and then I just want to take this
time to thank the brands that support
creators like myself through times like
this where we can't be adventuring
beyond the borders of our fence and it
does make things more restricting and I
just want to say thank you for having
our backs and keeping us creative
keeping us motivated one of those brands
being story blocks the sponsor of this
video this video wouldn't have been made
possible without story blocks because
you know like we've spoken about before
how to use stock footage from story
blogs in order to put behind a green
screen and some what made it seem as if
we were there so if you have in the need
for a quick b-roll flip after effects
templates or motion backgrounds story
blocks has got you covered like with
this video going and sourcing different
stocks from different areas around the
world and just seeing the sheer amount
of stocks that are available on story
blocks is insane so if I other creators
out there feeling stuck like you just
can't tell a story without a big wide or
a big drone shot or shot through the
forest - trust me it's all there on
story blocks and lastly all content is
royalty-free
so you can use it for commercial and
personal projects - like your YouTube
videos other than that please don't
forget to subscribe to my channel it's
just a simple click of a button make
sure you put the post
vacation Valon - this will ensure you
don't miss next week's video which is a
really exciting video a big
collaboration with lots of different
creators from all over the world and
making a seeing sounds super exciting
because I haven't done that in a while
so yeah other than that
don't forget your awesome grit and I'll
see you next week
[Music]